what's your ethnicity big guy and you're
a big ass Indian dude what do you do for
a living man what a waste of good
genetics is this your girl right here oh
okay you got a white girl all right so
you did something with the size you know
there's a sick guy right here your girl
is Indian stay true I see that two
Indians one set of happy Parents I got
it do your parents know about her yet no
no no no no no
shame on his face how long has it been
oh you don't have to tell them yet this
is wifey
when you right away watch this is that
wifey told you oh you got the ring there
you go how did you meet her in arranged
marriage I knew it I knew it dog
what do you do for a living
fake doctor that's what's up you are the
GED version of him